like off the top of my head I've been
getting into like fidget toys
recently I actually said there's not
what do you want a fidget spinner like
what do you want no not a fidget spinner
Joey okay is that not a fidget toy
that's that's a fidget toy made for
someone who doesn't fidget all right
like swear down I've seen like I've been
getting recommended a lot of different
fidget toy videos and some of them I'm
just like a that looks really really
good actually do you know one of the
best fidget toys I've had
recently it was a present that you gave
actually it was the belt buckle and and
so Conor like I asked for a belt right
and con of gave me a belt buckle and it
just has this really satisfying click
right when when you like flip it it has
such a strong satisfying click wait was
this what brand is it uh I think it was
Calvin CL it has such a satisfying click
when you rotate it and I'm not actually
used swear down swear down I have not
yet used it he's just sitting there in
his office just clicking away at this
bck this is like when parents buy their
kids like a ton of like or like when
they buy pets they buy like a cat or a
dog a bunch of amazing toys and then
playing with the spring on the door yeah
yeah literally S I haven't actually used
it as a bell yet cuz it's just been
sitting on my desk and I just like I
just twiddle with it because I'm just
like so do I have another do I have to
buy another belt that you actually use I
don't like I don't know CU ever last
year you like I need a belt to use and
now I find out you're using the [__]
thing just buy him another Calvin Klein
but only the belt buckle part yeah I
should yeah I should rip I've been I've
been getting curious about like
different fidget toys cuz I I bought one
in uh Korea and it was it was [__] I I
I've kind of realized the difference
between good fidget
toys there needs to be something like
satisfying well now I'm scared to buy
you any like fidget toy for Christmas
because there's a chance that I'll give
it to you and you be like this is [__] I
I want to your standards for fish choice
you want to know the funny origin of
where your belt came from where ibly
should say this so I I I I went to this
donkey hot and I remember you told me
you wanted this uh and I got sidetracked
I wasn't actually looking for your
birthday present uh so Christmas present
itras it Christmas Christmas last
Christmas and uh I went to uh this
really cool donkey hot that was like
eight floors or something in Al kaido
and there was a a $100 Gater machine and
I was like [__] yeah I was like [__]
okay in my head I was like this is
before if if if YouTube shorts on my
mind at the time I would have I would
have made a short about it something but
I was like well [__] I got I'm want to
find out so I just unloaded like 500
bucks into this thing to see what I got
my God and I realized I was like wait
hold on a second uh wait no was it 5000
I think it was 100 Buck like $60 ago uh
and the worst thing you could get you
basically got like a a a level so it's e
to A to B whatever and uh I got four e
which was the worst and one like C okay
H and the E's you could choose from this
cabinet a bunch of stuff uh and and I
was looking at the prices of some of
these things on Amazon and a lot of them
were more than ichiman oh and I was like
wait a second this is like this is great
yeah and so I got I got one of the belts
from that oh [__] cuz that belt was
going for like 80 bucks was that the E
rank one that was one of the worst
ranked ones yeah uh cuz I I I got a
gacha prize take it yeah but it was like
it was it was I I was looking on Amazon
it was more money to buy it on Amazon
than it was to play this GAA and lose
and then get it and I was like huh see
but that's cool but now that we've known
the true nature of what happened to this
Bel you basically paid 80 bucks for a
[__] fidget toy hey man I've seen
I've seen
$60 okay I've seen some of the price of
these fidget toys and some of them go
from like 10 bucks that's that's all the
like the [__] ones they can go for like
hundreds of bucks some of these fidget
toys because like so intricately
made Japanese engineering like [__]
insane [__] but we're not talking about
fidget toys we're not talking about
belts we're talking about our favorite
things of 2023 we've decided to make a
little 3x3 to kind of reflect on the
year of 2023 and uh basically share I
guess the nine things that we were
really invested in or we really want to
talk about that we discovered in 2023
yeah oh sorry okay who who go me one of
you preface not everything has to be
from 2023 just things that we discovered
or things that we enjoyed in 202 yeah
because we've had two three Christmas
episodes before so we thought we'd do
something different and just reflect on
we we're going to be self-indulgent and
just be like hey this is what we liked
in 2023 and it doesn't have to be any
theme doesn't be doesn't have to be any
particular thing can be literally
anything that we wanted to talk about
that we discovered in 2023 and if you
want trash taste odds are I imagine some
of these might have come up on trash
taste I've tried to pick stuff that I
haven't talked about so much on trash
taste before or things that fair enough
I've got a mix half I've definitely
spoke about a lot yeah I'm about mix as
well I think yeah so who wants to go
first why you you're the host off you
can go first okay bring on my 3x3 that I
definitely just scrambled together no
what the heck is
this okay okay okay you know you know
what's really funny I was thinking back
on like all right what are the like some
of the newer things that I got into in
2023 and I sat there and thought about
it and I was like damn am I getting old
or do I just not remember what happened
this year uh yes either that or you've
uh gone back to your [__] childhood
yeah I was going to say like if you
removed the crown this could be a kid
yeah
literally remove the crown what age uh
what age range are we
talking literally I think I might have G
back sometimes going back to the roots
is where it's at yeah man okay I got a
air yeah Crown ain't no way come on okay
legitimately legitimately I started
watching the crown I didn't really start
watching it this year it was more like
late last year that I like kind of
discovered and uh you know at first when
I looked at the concept of this show I
was just like oh it's about like the
British Monarchy I didn't really care
about the I mean every Australian
doesn't really care about the British
Monarchy all that kind of stuff but I
thought [__] whatever I'll give it a go
I'll give it a watch and I really
[__] enjoyed it like it's a really
good sure I would like to give my
thoughts on the show to see if you kind
of feel similarly okay uh first like two
to three seasons Banger television
Banger television some of the best out
there because I feel like the crown pre
like televised history was really really
interesting yeah absolutely and then
afterwards especially when the crown of
season 4 and light season were really
[__] bad uh I thought the latest
season of the crowd the crown the one
with like Diana well all the Diana
seasons have been some of the most
boring TV I've ever seen in my life I
think it's definitely gone down since
yeah when like Diana came into the
picture like definitely that far in the
ground yet okay yeah cuz like right now
it's like season six I think which is
the last season three seasons of this
show to Diana yeah what I mean like look
I get it like now that I have like fully
sat through the entire series and I've
actually learned a lot like it's
actually kind of an achievement this
show made me kind of interested in
learning about the history of like the
British
I didn't a sh but yeah asor like first
seasons of like you know Elizabeth was
still like very very young and just got
you know just became queen stuff like
that that sh was super interesting cuz
i' never learned anything about that and
again it was just like really well-made
television that actually made me give a
[__] about something I previously didn't
give a [__] about I had to I had to
constantly catch myself in the first few
seasons being nearly caring about the
family I was like no no well an I'm not
forgetting he nearly got me I during
season one I was still like in denial I
was like I mean yeah this is cool but
like I don't quite care yet and then
season two here I'm like all right I'm
invested you know when you like start
watching that like trash TV show that
your significant other is watching and
then you start off being like what is
this [__] but then you stick around for
a while and then a couple days later you
like fully invested in it like wait
honey can we uh watch can we watch the
next episode please it's like what what
do you mean you watch their head what
the
[__] so the current I'd say like out of
all of the Netflix shows kind of live
action shows I'd say that one probably
stuck out to me the most because again
it made me care about something I
previously would have never thought I'd
get into I think if they had just
wrapped up the Diana stuff in like a
season as opposed to three we would have
been how many seasons of the crown is
there now six currently six and half of
it is di [__] yeah like three like
four yeah four and five is like very
heavily focused on Diana got through
divorce the beginning of season 3 and
then I stopped and then I was like H
probably the best thing to do probably
yeah it kind of goes downhill a little
bit I think second half of season 6 has
just come out which I haven't watched
yet but apparently that's going to be
like the end of the series cuz you know
what what are they going to do after
that